[Music]
you'll be forgiven for not recognizing
Assassin's Creed as it exists today I
myself played every game since the
beginning and then about two hours of
unity before I fell off I only came back
to the series once the yearly release
schedule had been ditched playing
origins felt like returning to my
hometown to find that everything had
changed in place of a historical
playground focused on social stealth I
found an action game centered around
progression and loot upgrades that's not
to say I disliked origins in fact it's
one of my favorite entries in the series
I loved the world its characters and its
balance between the old and the new I
also loved its restrain but within the
size of its map and its willingness to
not smother me with its activities but
when compared to its predecessor
syndicate the difference is night and
day origins almost completely abandons
the idea of social stealth you are no
longer blending into crowds hiding in
plain sight or causing commotions to
slip on notice into enemy territory as
many fans have pointed out getting rid
of that social self is a pretty big deal
it's what made the series feel so fresh
in that trailer 12 years ago and I find
it ironic that a series so focused on
the exploration of DNA that it seems to
have forgotten its own in a GDC talk
earlier this year
Jean Gaston creative director of AC for
Black Flag and origins explored the
franchise's evolution throughout the
decade he recalled the creation of the
first game when developers behind prince
of persia sands of time were given two
mandates to prepare for the next console
generation and to reinvent the
action-adventure genre to do both the
team would focus on three pillars combat
navigation and social stealth if you
played any of the Assassin's Creed games
or at least any of the AC games before
origins you can see these three tenets
in abundance
the brutal close quarters combat the
fluid and stylish parkour the act of
using crowds as camouflage emerging only
to kill before vanishing again right
under your opponent's nose as each new
AC released in each new historical
setting it was these three tenets that
tie the titles together of course
there's also humane
lore of the series and it's so obvious
that Gaston didn't even need to include
it in this presentation it's the
historical settings in a recent
interview with The Guardian Jade Raymond
head of EA motive founder of Ubisoft
Toronto and producer of early Assassin's
Creed games called the historical
settings sandboxes for creatives by
establishing a foundation and a
fictional justification for these times
and places
Ubisoft was creating a sustainable
ecosystem new developers could rise up
prove themselves put their mark on the
franchise and keep the series fresh this
led to innovation at a steady pace you
can look at each game in the series and
clearly remember its flagship feature
ac2 had the mission variety that ac1 was
lacking ac3 introduced naval combat
which is pretty prevalent in a series
now ac syndicate gave us dual
protagonists and the fan-favorite
rope launcher unity for all of its flaws
paved the way for better navigation and
added co-op to the main storyline even
the fantastic and often overlooked rogue
reversed the roles of Templar and
assassin turning you from the hunter
into the hunted
rogue also told one of the best stories
in the entire series but that's another
video so I'll leave that claim
unsubstantiated here and entirely up to
my own opinion
[Music]
[Music]
all-in-all Ubisoft set out to create a
franchise and instead stumbled upon a
global phenomenon it now comprises
comics graphic novels short films a
feature-length movie and numerous
spin-off games since 2007 only two years
have passed without a mainline
Assassin's Creed entry it became so
pervasive that many felt that had grown
stale by the time syndicate rolled
around with its two playable characters
and an engrossing Victorian London
setting it kind of felt as if we had
seen it all leaving aside the possible
time periods Ubisoft might still explore
it seemed like the well was about to run
dry
Ubisoft CEO Eve game all cited several
reasons for the lack of an assassin's
Creed in 2016 one was syndicates
relatively disappointing sales another
was the need to develop new engines as
the foundations for future games and
although guillermo himself didn't
mention it various reports about
development crunch and long working
hours leaked from various levels of
Ubisoft Studios so for one reason or
another it was time to give Assassin's
Creed a break if only for a little while
by the time we first glimpsed Assassin's
Creed origins it had been in development
for three years
several Ubisoft Studios led by UB
Montreal revealed origins at e3 2017
showing the mega byuk in his Egyptian
setting this also confirmed an earlier
leak from kotaku when origins was still
known by its codename Empire the trailer
also showed a new style of combat
swapping the animation focused melees of
earlier games for a system based on
hitboxes and deliberate timing as more
news poured out from e3 it became clear
that origins was also heavily influenced
by RPG progression with a full-fledged
color-coded loot system where a knock
four by x hood his hidden blade or the
assassins iconic leap of faith it could
have been a whole new series like I said
before I love origins I love its
characters its inhabitants its vast
stretches of empty desert I love its
ability to let me find my own story but
also the confidence to tell its own when
need be I also respect the hell out of
its writers for tackling one of the most
frequently fan or
busted settings and for knocking it out
of the park it was a technological jump
to be sure but also a cultural one and
it represented a major shift in what the
developers wanted Assassin's Creed to be
in this way origins was a major turning
point and as of now I'm worried about
the series new direction Assassin's
Creed Odyssey is one of my favorite
games this year and I had a blast
sinking seventy five hours into its
massive Greek archipelago but still it
feels as if you be soft emphasized the
wrong aspects from a sea origins its new
identity as one of hundreds of side
quests numerous overlapping systems and
a loot fest that rivals that of destiny
or diablo years ago assassin's creed was
setting precedents for open-world design
now despite the fun i'm having with a
series it feels as if it's playing
catch-up
I don't wanna complain about an
abundance of content and I sure as hell
don't wanna complain about having fun
but still at a certain point I have to
wonder if you be soft strayed too far
I'm almost always of the opinion that
developers should evolve whenever
possible it brings a wider spectrum of
games and experiences to the table and
allows for fresh ideas to enter the ring
at a regular pace but I can also
empathize with the people who feel as if
Assassin's Creed is absent from the
modern video game landscape social
stealth is almost completely gone the
map feels more about size than substance
and the franchise feels built around its
progression rather than its gameplay
this can still be fun and I have had a
ton of it but at what point does
Assassin's Creed lose its identity
at its core Assassin's Creed's plot is
one of freedom versus control on the one
hand you have the Templars an ancient
order hell-bent on maintaining order
through power and influence the
assassins on the other hand represent
the opposite complete and utter freedom
even if it means overwhelming chaos the
story of the franchise's evolution is
the exact same one freedom versus
control and with all of its fourth wall
breaking and self-aware storytelling I
can't imagine this irony is lost on the
developers they themselves are
constantly grappling with that same
dilemma trying to find that balance
between the control and order of earlier
games and the player freedom of recent
ones I think there is a balance to
strike and it is fascinating watching
them trying to
I get Assassin's Creed as it stands
today is the result of a 10-year search
for an identity in fact you could argue
that it's that very search itself that
has come to define the series I have no
clue where that next 10 years will bring
us but I think one thing is for certain
that journey will be entertaining